to hospital visits the weirdest spa ever
and richard marx i'm lauren zima and
it's time for roses and rose say hi you
guys
oh thank you so much for joining me we
are here to recap episode 3 of Becca
kufran season of The Bachelorette let's
get into it just as quickly as David
probably got into that ambulance so Wow
so much to digest you guys I thought we
started off strong with Jordan picking a
fight by saying David walks around quote
scumbags all day but things only
escalated from there why is that
something to get mad at someone about
they're just cooking a lot of eggs
whatever
don't drink every time Jordan makes a
comment because he's great TV and you'd
be on the floor
he's a dry chicken as long as I stay
charismatic I think Rebecca's gonna keep
me around
maybe being me is gonna win me the Rose
tonight thanks George so the group date
is announced and cold his hoodie is up
and you know that when a guy's hoodie is
up he's feeling down he's sad because he
told Beca about Tia now he thinks him
and Becca are not connecting and you
know what then I realized all the guys
are in the sweatshirts because it's
raining and hey men dress for the job
you want not the one you have and the
job you want is to be Becca's man
that's some life advice
so Becca's girls are here to hang and we
talked to TIA about Colton and this got
weird because I love all these women and
I love Tia but Tia was pretty much flat
out saying that she thought Colton dated
her because was he thinking that I said
you might be the bachelor what why what
are those motives Colton what I think if
you really like someone you would say
please don't be the Bachelorette I want
to date you so why was he doing that he
was dating her thinking she was gonna be
the Bachelorette and he was gonna go on
the show I don't know we'll see
I questioned if Colton truly signed up
for this because he thought Tia might be
the bachelor right so they're doing a
spa day and that's just about as weird
as everything that Tia had to say about
Colton you guys what was this
we saw some signage like dressing rooms
this way what's pi is a dressing room
this isn't a theater you go to the
locker room then there was some sugar
scrub that looked like pudding Becca was
wearing a swimsuit for some reason and
then you know drink every time you saw a
spa thing that wasn't a real spa thing
the women were putting their feet into
what looked like tubs that you would use
for chips for an outdoor party from
Target did somebody go to Target for
this date it felt like someone was sent
to target for this date and you know
what I don't need for a man to paint my
toenails
you're probably gonna do a bad job and
it's not sex scene we're not in middle
school so I don't really like anything
about this date it was a lot of touching
though and I want to commend the
producers on putting Tia and Colton
together in a room and then immediately
making everyone touch that was so
awkward
[Music]
Jason Jason so Becca forgot someone's
name Jason's and I want to commend the
producers drink every time we want to
come in I'm God we love them for showing
that moment the leads probably forget
the names all the time all the time and
Becca says she's so happy she haven't we
all been there like I'm so happy I put
on deodorant today because I flew here
from New York earlier after the Tony is
off check out all the coverage easy
online comm not related to the
Bachelorette shameless plug and don't
worry I'm just getting started with the
musicals because we all know what
happened later in this episode I really
like Justin he is so cute Becca is into
Jason and let me know what you guys
thought were you surprised by this I was
I did not see this coming she told him I
have a little crush on you
she's got some unexpected taste but I
think in the end the beefy guys are
gonna win out because that's what her ex
Ross from you know who season looked
like and that's what her friends have
told me she's into and so sometimes
physical type matters a KY Colton's
still around anyway one day I said
congratulations you've reached 4,000
matches on tinder in 2017 drink every
time Jordan says something weird
don't do it oh then Jordan says and
silver spoon hang on not the phrase babe
I'm drinking this real slow cuz it's
sparkling shale be drink your juice it's
been a pleasure I also want to say let's
drink every time one of the guys was
just sitting there trying not to laugh
at Jordan David's ridiculous fight like
wills was so cute he's like jacket to
the face and Jason was like pillow to
the face and just any object that could
obscure their view from this insanity
I know it's hard with me being like a
model it's not and then Jordan tells
David it's been a pleasure and Will's
almost spits out his drink and it is
just so funny I'm a golden retriever
so another great line from Jordan he
compared himself to a golden retriever
so that he'll just be sitting there
waiting for you do whenever you want him
to do great so golden and Becca sit down
and look you guys I was shocked that
Colton got the Rose shocked were you
tell me he got the group-date rose and
they kissed quite a lot and I think
again this just speaks to Becca's
physical attraction to Colton she said
he's easy on the eyes and I also think
that it speaks to that you get so little
time with the lead you guys you really
do I recently interviewed Dean on Girt
and he told me that I night one he
literally only got 90 seconds with
Rachel Lindsay I thought people were
always exaggerating about that but
you've got so little time and so she's
only basing her opinion of Colton on
these very little moments she has and in
those moments he's been sexy to her and
he's been honest to her and so that's
that's honesty and you can't beat that I
guess on this show anyway also when
Jordan was gesturing with his very red
nails from the spa I was really dying
red rose nails Chris gets the one-on-one
another surprise the Jason surprise the
Colton Rose surprise and the Chris
surprise drink everytime we're surprised
who's Chris Wright and everybody what a
moment we had Chris and Becca walk into
the room and he says something like we
walk through the doors and Richard marks
a Grammy award-winning artists is saying
there playing the piano nobody
recognizes Richard Marx on sight nobody
I like Richard Marx's music and I don't
even know what he looks like
today I'm gonna help you write your love
song so their date is to write songs I
think you brought out my smile on this
rainy day and tonight I want to hear
more of what you have to say that goes
was cute Chris's was full of too many
multi syllabic words for a song I think
he said like evolution or envision and
like that's hard to rhyme with things
other than vision when I first met you
you were humming behind me but from here
now I want you singing beside me and
Becca's and Chris's lyrics we're both
just really poems they were poems
weren't they
so if we use what Becca wrote and
luckily Richard Marx swooped in to save
the day
hmm and make them into songs because
Richard Marx drink for Richard Marx but
since we just love right here waiting
for you so much and since we didn't
really vibe and jam with the songs they
wrote we have a special little tune of
our own
[Music]
roses apart day after day a the men
slowly go who in seed to win Becca's
heart
they play all of the games but fall out
of bed in pain they see her next to
never but trying to win a forever
wherever you go whatever you do Jordan
will be right here waiting for you
whatever it takes or how his nose breaks
David will fight with Jordan - thank you
everyone Tony nominee 2019 me and JC
will be up there at the Tonys mmm what a
dream it was for me the inner musical
theater geek and me I always played a
villain or a weirdo though like a nanny
I was Miss Hannigan
and Alice in Wonderland I was the
Griffon that's a bird I wore a beak
anyway okay so and you Chris to be able
to open up to me about why that was
actually significant for him back to
beckoned Chris's date his story about
his dad and getting rejected by his
father and his family I really liked him
and God I know they said a lot on this
show but I understand why they say be
vulnerable you don't have that much time
with the person and he knocked it out of
the park so good job Chris and thank God
they swooped back in and Richard Marx
did perform right here waiting for you
because we need it that didn't mean okay
and then things have taken a turn
suddenly David slumped on the floor
there's blood everywhere
ambulance sirens are going what happened
we did not believe for a second that
Jordan push David you guys
Chris Harrison comes in to tell Becca
what happened in the truth is that David
fell out of his bunk bed what so it's a
camp injury I don't know they said I
loved again credit to the producers they
didn't clean up the blood they had shots
of the blood and they're still and they
said he was in the intensive care unit
but somehow he was able to just jump on
a call real quick so that's great you
know conference them in and he's like
[Music]
which is just the most privileged
sounding explanation I don't think he
meant it that way but Oh David I David
proof for bed as a reminder David was
the chicken suit guy so what a journey
he's had already on this show chickens
can't fly and I think that we learned
that last night I will say I'm surprised
it hasn't happened before they all sleep
on these bunk beds and have for years so
maybe a first for you David and then we
have a group date with more sports and I
don't mean to sound like me but God
there have been a lot of sports so far
this season
[Applause]
Becca Vaughn Chris Harrison is
announcing it with someone is probably
very famous in sports and I think that
Chris Harrison misses Bachelor Winter
Games and I do too and so he wants to
announce things and he's great at it so
that's awesome but we're on this sport
state and God the irony of it is injury
number two clay gets hurt
clay Harbor an actual football player
falls and just like actual athletes do
instantly knows he's broken something
paddy freakin did and he had to leave
after playing football this is like a
contract issue or something I don't know
it wouldn't you guys I was sad to see
him go because he was saying the most
wonderful thing is he said quote being a
man is making her choices and tough
decisions living with them and living
with that that's a good song lyric
wherever you go so a couple other
shoutouts Blake really seemed to be on
the struggle bus like Holly's girlfriend
tonight really like Blake there's a part
of me a big part of me that's saying if
they don't go all the way I know it's so
early to call this you guys but what do
you think I just think he's very
well-spoken and sweet and smart and
after riding in on a horse and then an
ox he's turned out to be a surprisingly
good dresser I didn't see that coming so
I'm just saying you guys wherever you go
whatever you do my Roseanne I will be
right here waiting for you and I want to
thank you for being here with me and
with JC on this big group date that will
never thank you guys so much for
watching please let me know what you
thought of this episode I always love to
hear from you and I will see you next
week
I didn't read much of this it's hard
it's sparkling bye